روسيا تطلي سفنها الحربيه بخطوط سوداء
حيله تعود الى الحرب العالميه الاولى
والثانيه تستخدمها موسكو لارباك المسيرات
الاوكرانيه وفق ما كشفه موقع انسايدر صور
الاقمار الصناعيه وثقت في الثاني والعشرين
من يونيو الفرقات الروسيه
في ميناء سيفاستوبول وكذلك ثلاثه سفن
حربيه اخرى مطليه بالاسود في محاوله واضحه
لارباك الهجمات الاوكرانيه السفن الاربعه
المطليه بالاسود تحمل على متنها صواريخ
كاليبر والتي استخدمت في ضربات مدمره في
جميع انحاء اوكرانيا تكتيك التمويه البحري
هذا فعال ضد الطائرات المسيره تحديدا وهذا
الاسلوب تم استخدامه في الحرب العالميه
الاولى والثانيه وكانت بريطانيا حينها
رائده باستخدام الخطوط والانماط المبهره
كما نشاهد في هذه الصوره التي تعود الى
العام
1917 ايضا اوكرانيا تستخدم منذ فتره طويله
المركبات الفضائيه الامريكيه كوسيله رخيصه
ومبهجه لمضايقه الاصول الروسي خاصه في
ميناء سيفا ستوبول حسب طبعا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات